everybody so you should know that I
didn't want to give this talk so I seen
people going away from the door right
now oh then I can go see it something
else I didn't mean to give this talk I
prepared this talk for a different
audience but all they wrote me email all
the model one of the organizers and he's
not here he doesn't care but at any rate
so all they wrote an email and said you
know we want to talk about comparisons
between programming languages and be as
controversial as it as you can as
controversies you can
not knowing who he's dealing with here
we here we go
so I'm going to talk about the most
average function there is the most
average function in the world and please
give me red cards only I only want the
red card I'm gonna measure my
performance of red cards so you know
starting with a simple question what is
a good language for getting work done
well I say work I mean computation I
mean you know actual verifiable
computation that does something useful
for humankind and I'm sure each of us
has a few ideas about what what some
criteria would be and mine are the
following I would like a language that
is algorithmically inclined it makes it
easy to take an algorithm from a book
and translate it into code I'm seeing a
few nods thank you very much
I feel better already I also want the
language that keeps it real and by that
I mean acknowledges the realities of the
hardware it runs on ok so it's kind of
well yeah we don't want to implement
algorithms but we don't implement
algorithms on an abstract machine we
want to implement on an actual machine
that you know Huff's and puffs and hell
you know it gets hot and you know dirty
and you know leaks oil and that kind of
stuff right number three my criteria is
allows you to do what you want to do
this is a bit solemn and I find very
interesting whenever I find my I you
know I want to do X I know it's part
Cybil there's no loss of physics
preventing it yet my environment does
not allow me to do it that's a red flag
right you want to be allowed to do what
you want to do and after you've done it
code reads like it does what you want it
to do and that's a test that some
languages such as Perl don't quite pass
right so you know that they're contest
like what's what's the longest sequence
of random characters that Perl is gonna
consider a valid program in that kind of
stuff right so you know you do want to
have such a language that you can read
because code is more read and written
all the time and that kind of stuff so
no surprise here now you know just just
for kicks
I totally agreed that URIs might be
different you may be looking for
different abstractions different things
that are that matter to you and that's
totally fine there's no contest there
but Baku before because all they wrote
me I'm the guy with a really loud
microphone so I get to say what I think
please feel free to interrupt me and say
you know that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard so everything inclined I can
take an algorithm from math book or
write my own and it's going to translate
somewhat naturally into code and if you
do look at at any algorithms book you're
going to see that most algorithms and
tell mutation or at least many of them
I'm sure you know this function of pure
function languages that do not allow
mutation and all of a sudden I have a
problem it's like well that means I
can't do what I want to do so I want
mutation as an option of course I think
that the answer of functional Probie
there isn't there are ways to allow
mutation even within functional context
etc etc but you know pretty much against
a by one mutation and I want to have
things like a race and I want to have
referential data structures for lists
and trees and
hash tables and whatnot so these are
things that you would want to have
algorithmic incline of course you know
it's not only algorithms you want to do
because there's a lot of second-order
issues you need to worry about such as
you know you want to maintain your code
you want to eliminate a variety of
classes of bugs by doing type checking
you know even unit testing you should be
able to pass for function to another in
a higher order function manner so you
know before long you the list gets quite
long right and to there handling and
stuff
kymmie keeping it real I think there
should be some honest protocol between
your language and the machine a machine
is going to have fixed sized numbers
it's going to have fixed size numbers
it's going to have mutation memory is
going to be mutable right it's going to
have contiguous loosely typed arrays
because the entire memory is like a
large array so this would be sort of the
simplest data structure that is one by
one representing a computer that would
be an array addresses of things are
things you can load the point into
register and that's a thing right it's a
word that you get to load and interpret
different way than you would interpret
an integer you want layout control you
want to put your data in memory by hand
as you wish right you want to have
control over how data gets placed in
memory and you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be of find yourself in the
need to rewrite from prototype to
production as it happens with many
languages that ignore these realities
right so you know all of a sudden we're
looking here and you know it's I I came
in peace I mean I don't want to
antagonize anybody but their language is
that like first order of business
there's no fixed size numbers
and first of all there's no erase
everything is an associative array or is
a list and this doesn't quite vibe with
me
does it vibe with you didn't I was just
saying darn languages that decide from
day one they're not going to have fixed
sized integers they're not going to have
contiguous erase this you know the way
we're all on this machine that has a
fixed size integers and a race is we're
not we're gonna ignore that
we're not gonna accept that at all yes
please so the point was well you say you
you know memories contiguous and sort of
flattened and mice but actually current
machines they have multiple levels of
cache hierarchies and they have out of
order execution right I would not mind
primitives for expressing that within a
language but what machines do with these
cache allocation and such is they they
make this model fast like for example
the cache memory that you know if you're
like let's say you know one gigabyte of
cache memory that's not going to be
added to your capacity it's just going
to be used to repetitiously without even
knowing by the by the machine to emulate
for you a contiguous block of memory yes
question ok all right
he's here ok
so you know that made that great issues
with ideological languages an
ideological language is one that creates
a sweeping uh you know has a sweeping of
first order decision that's going to
affect the entire dis the entire design
of the rest of the language for example
everything an object because you know on
a machine not everything is an object
there are things that are not objects
and this is the way it is I mean you
can't escape it so once you claim
everything Islam is an object you lose
the ability to represent with fidelity
things that are not objects everything
is a function church numerals are the
most terrifying thing in the universe
the notion that I need you know I can
represent a number by just taking the
steps from number zero all the way to
that number is to me very scary
everything is a list what happened to a
race so let's choose the slowest data
structure that works and use that for
everything you know we make that our
this is our first business decision you
know first our business ladies and
gentlemen everybody please in line we're
gonna use the list from now on as
everything represented in our machine
no thank you everything is immutable
I love functional programming I love
email ability I love purity in public
we're going to private I'm I love purity
I love these are good principles to live
by and not to live by to to live in to
to aspire to in a way are synthetically
if you wish but to have that as an
imposition to not give me the option
that that's a bit of a problem because
you know the machine does have mutable
data and actually he made a good point
earlier actually the you know mutation
on the machine is
be 10 years nowadays because whenever
you take and make that cash dirty which
is already kind of a bad word you make
the cash dirty and you need to write it
back and there needs to be protocols for
ensuring things are maintained synchrony
you know synchronized across threads and
all that nonsense
so mutability is already kind of a
tenuous proposition in current machines
however MIT ability of registers is
great works awesomely and registers are
local and generally you know why is in a
while I do want to meet eight things and
you know everything somehow I'm gonna
let you fill out the blanks I don't
think everything is somehow is the
appropriate way of thinking of
contemporary machine there of course
second order issues here we have things
like dependency management famous code
from Uncle Bob all the techniques in
software engineering are something you
know have something to do with
dependency management and I thought
that's kind of a stupid thing to say
and then I fears later I thought yeah he
was right he was right here he was right
there he was right there he was right
there so dependency match is kind of an
important topic for for us debugging
unit testing maintenance and all of
these higher-order issues are good to
have in a good language who knows about
these two fine gentlemen what did they
write famously
the structure interpretation of computer
programs famous book and they have a
very nice pull out code programs must be
written for humans to look at and only
incidentally for machines to execute an
anonymous reply to that would be the
fact that you show the same foreign to
the human in the machine is an
abomination
it is tragically flawed it's as if you
know there's no there's no interface
between the language and you as a reader
versus the language and the machine
through the compiler it's like you're
using like you're driving a car but
instead of having like a nice you know a
nice car and it's inside it's all i
can't covered and you need to kind of
hold you know the engine there you know
with your hand and it just sparked the
plugs yourself with a you know with a
lighter and all that kind of stuff so
it's you know what the machine uses for
running you know it presents the same
interface to you that's a bit extreme
however we have no idea how to do better
people have tried they've tried
graphical programming it works for up to
15 liners programs up to 15 lines we
know how to do with graphics and all the
squares and all the squiggles and all
the you know it can look clouds and all
the good things you can draw in up to 15
lines it scales perfectly we tried with
business logic you know let's write the
business rules you know nicely in like
COBOL and then we have a program that is
like it works etcetera 50 lines of code
these represent like 150 lines of COBOL
right so that didn't quite work so
people try the number of things
Microsoft has done has a project that is
aimed at non programs to write business
rules and it's a kind of a long going
research project I'm not sure does not
know what the status is of that project
I haven't heard of it in a while so I
assume they kind of dropped it I think
I'm gonna get hate mail for this
anyhow I do think that this is kind of
an interesting disconnect between
between you know the fact that you are
looking at the same code that's going to
make up exactly the on the substrate I
think it's kind of there's a problem
here anyhow remember doing what you want
to do we want to do things like want to
implement algorithms and the algorithms
may be just a bit different depending on
particulars of the machine and whatnot
and you know end up implementing I
noticed the same algorithm over and over
again I'm sure many of you have written
your own things that do searching or
that do some insertion is something or
that do computer unique something in
somewhere or that you know do a lot of
classic tasks yet once again just
because the setup is just a bit
different right and those of you who
worked at more than one company I'm sure
you kind of take your your little tool
chest or like you know your C or C++
code or Python scripts and stuff you
just take them with you it's not illegal
because just a few hundreds thousands
all or millions of lines it's you know
what's a few million lines of code
between friends you just take your
little tool chain and say I have this
little function here that verifies that
and does this and that does the other
and it works for me really nice and it
provides for me some nice tools
otherwise just end up writing them
yourself and that's the way the cookie
crumbles so I claim that we are dealing
with an elusive form of duplication in
our daily life in code that it's so
pervasive that we kind of trained
ourselves not even see it anymore I'm
seeing nods
so by means of example we're going to
write together the average function
literally like the average function that
computes the average of a few numbers
and if you google for you know what is
the average of numbers you find add up
all the numbers and then divide by how
many numbers they are you can explain
that to a six-year-old okay if you crack
up on any math book you're gonna find
this notation which is X with a bar
which means average of X's and that's
going to be one by n the summation of
all X's so I have the notion of
summation I have I'm iterating through
things right and kind of doing a few
motions that are my algorithm it's
really simple right if you want more
complicated should go back in time and
go in my talk this morning which was a
bit more complicated than this but
here's stuck right this is the algorithm
we're going to look at and we want to do
a few simple things to make sure we
don't screw up a few details
number one we should not walk our input
twice do you agree hands up if you agree
we don't want to go once to sum the
numbers and once again to count the
numbers agreed this is an important
point thank you yes and thank you yes
I'm just saying like that for the camera
because nobody's doing anything okay so
we want to not I mean imagine
mathematicians don't do this you know
there's a joke with a mathematician the
physician and you know the the
programmer who have the you know the
water in the coffee and the programs
throws away the water and applies the
routine that he has already which is
filler thing with new water so not good
I mean a mathematician would laugh at
this would be like hey Jack guess what I
spoke to this programmer and guess how
they do average
they go once through the numbers they
add them and then they go once again and
count them and then they do the
operation so you don't want to do that
it's just goofy we also want to be
generic and this is sort of word that
kind of this is our machine part we want
to work with all reasonably applicable
types that means things like small
integers large integers single precision
floating point numbers blood you know
double precision large floating-point
numbers are limited precision be
integers unlimited precision floating
point unlimited precision real numbers
numbers that you have not seen yet they
have not been invented yet you want to
be able to compute the average of things
that you haven't seen yet and be
recognizable you want the algorithm to
look a bit like this you don't to go
wildly away from the notion that you're
summing some numbers in you're making
one division here kind of home-free we
have agreement on that ladies and
gentlemen thank you so what's the best
language in the world has go so I swear
to God first I chose that this is not
cherry picked I chose the function and
then I googled Haskell average function
it turns out it's a research project has
called types this is kind of copy and
paste or maybe though I couldn't even
parse the sentence Haskell theis
frustrating maybe are frustrating water
a simple average function it seems like
the simplest thing in the world right
wrong so this program you know Stack
Overflow couldn't figure out how to
implement the average in Haskell by the
way list also has I couldn't find any
average function in list that doesn't
want the input twice I just it doesn't
exist it's against the unwritten laws of
Lisp
you can't write it if you write you can
explode okay that's it's the loft I
didn't make the rules in Haskell however
it can but it's just difficult so
finally so there's you know there's
discussion on Stack Overflow people kind
of going up and down or whatever and
they say well here's the thing you say
average axis sequels real to fraction
some X's / generate length and axis well
that's kind of who knows what the
difference between generic length and
length is does the wrong variance but
general length is able to compute the
length of a list of integrals in the
list of floating-point numbers or
fractional rational numbers or whatever
so it's drinking two things so you can
express with the same code the average
of rational numbers and integers cool
also have this real to frac very nice
however the problem is it walks the
input twice so it still walks the input
twice even though it looks already kind
of elaborate fine
any ideas on how to improve that yes
please
you make it a function where I
accumulate the sum and you accumulate
that simultaneously and the nd have
both right in my case I have a different
slightly different solution just a bit
I googled again I could like you know
Haskell average function walks the input
just once that sound like that I even
forgot and that took us to this solution
of course the X Bank patterns good
friend of course you gotta use that it's
obvious I did not write this code and
this is not a joke this is a serious
it's actually a blog post it's a blog
post on how to write the average
function in Haskell it's part of a
series of blog posts on how to write the
average function in Haskell I am not
kidding I think it does what he said it
does you walk the list you accumulate
things because I can see here you some a
plus B and if some C plus one because
you want to accumulate a guy like an
idiot and then you apply to zero zero
and you know magic happens and boom you
got it yay all right well I gotta give
it to Haskell it looks almost exactly
like like this it looks like very like
amazingly similar I can look at this you
know I can tell the difference is just
the font that's it there's no
substantive difference here that I can
I'm gonna get hidden hate mail for that
I'm gonna be destroyed
alright so let's take a look at the
implementation in the different language
and it's a simple modest function that
says average sequence and it does a loop
and pretty much what you'd expect
there is this notation so for those of
you who use C++ this is this way of
writing this is a template function in
templatized by seq writes a sequence so
this means this is a generic parameter
and this is a regular parameter to the
function so I'm going to have a sequence
of anything and I'm going to sum them up
and of course for this to work the you
know the sum must be edible from from X
and must be divisible by X is that
length and stuff like that this is no
matter start because it doesn't satisfy
many of our requirements for example it
doesn't work with anything that summable
let's fix that just to preempt a
possible protest people say recursion is
better and recursion in this case does
not work you must do non tail recursion
non tail recursion means it's going to
consume linear time linear heap linear
stack in the size of the input right if
you say sum if you say here sum plus
sequel average of X's without the first
element right so that would be the
recursive solution which is taught in
all functional programming courses and
that's actually not tail recursive which
means it kind of it violates an
important law of whatever which is well
we don't a function that consumes linear
memory just to come just to compute
something that should be done in
constant space I find it quite
interesting that in the same I was at
the university taking classes and in one
one class they literally dislike a 10:00
a.m. we teach us complexity and you know
constant space is better than linear
space and whatever polynomial space and
so there's this hierarchy of P spaces
and whatnot right and then you're like
okay fine wow that's cool so we want
constant space all the algorithms that
matter should be done in as little space
as possible
and then that means
break and then there's a function of
paren quest ah yes space we don't care
yeah we this is not something we do so I
find this quite hypocritical but there
is a version that does not require
linear stack space it's a function that
defines a function inside as an
accumulator and just because you could
have any name I called it Hitler you can
tell my feelings about this approach so
the way Hitler works is you pass it the
seed of computation this would be my sum
and this would be my count and it's
going to invoke itself recursively in a
tail manner and then we're kind of
nicely done right okay I forgot to
divide here something oh yeah no it's
okay so anyway this kind of approach is
not something that I would condone
definitely not and again it doesn't look
like anything close to the nice math
formula which does one iteration is done
fine how about this recurrence it
doesn't take a Ramanujan to write this
formula which is computes the average of
n plus 1 numbers given the average of n
numbers in the next number agreed
think it over it takes a few seconds
because this a n would be the average of
the previous numbers and you multiply by
n the N goes away so you have all of the
numbers summed and n divided by n plus 1
you get the average of n plus 1 what's
the trouble with this function what's
the trouble with this recurrence formula
please you're going to lose precision I
love it because it's not on the slide so
you risk to accumulators because you do
a bunch of multiplications and divisions
and you
going to slowly go insane right it's
like you eat a bit of lead every day I
think it slowly kind of mercury insane
right what are the disadvantages it's on
the slide for every you know to get to
the average of n numbers you're gonna
have to do n multiplications and
divisions and two n additions no thank
you bye miss of race hands who agrees
that this is not an effective way to do
things
thank you very much I call unanimity
except for the people who are sleeping
however people do this
I found it done in a public library of a
programming language standard library of
a programming language and when I
pointed that out I was destroyed
and I read it please help me define the
most average function there is so I
posted this on the rust reddit group
I love rust don't get me wrong I love it
great marketing I love it so I wrote
pretty much what I told you how did it
go about this and it's etc well I didn't
get a lot of votes all right
and then I was you know my glasses so
there we go alright so here's what I
write when I discovered so this is
actually in the rust standard library
top line do you guys see from the back
Paul can you see okay let me make just a
bit bigger so I found this in in the
rust and a library it has a statistics
package which is you know professional
written it's kind of a thing and I said
that's sorry
and the road that's a terrible way of
computing the mean of anything grossly
inefficient and Mar by accumulating
errors so bad in fact I am melody from a
review of solutions I found on a net in
a recent talk a better way to go would
be to keep the accumulated some and do
the division upon the mean being
requested
of course the for the sorry Dom the
right formula one here the right
recurrence is with the sum you keep the
sum as a running recurrence and whenever
you ask for the average of course I give
you the sum divided by the number so you
do only one division when asked like as
things go like like right now you do a
division for each iteration so I don't
know you know is this foul language who
thinks this is offensive I mean I'm a
bit insecure right now because here's
what happened first of all I my post got
like minus 18 points which is kind of a
negative record and then you ask someone
you know I see a bunch of downloads I
ask which which parts of what I wrote
were uncool by community standards
Thanks
well I will happily download people who
I think are obnoxious the problem is I
touched the sacred cow the moment you
criticize the standard library of the
Ross program language you're gonna have
a bad day and so I did I was like well
there's no more there's not nothing
significant in this thread except that I
was left out the door nobody one has -
not what I wanted to do nobody cared I
didn't get any advice I didn't get any
any light I did get a lot of heat though
all right so now let's actually do the
right thing and look at a few problems
that kind of take us from the nice
algorithms world into the concrete bits
and pieces world well first of all like
how do you deal with averaging integrals
consider this you have
an image and you want to compute the
average pixel whatever intensity color
or not and you're averaging 8 bit
numbers how would you go about it
what types do you use for your summation
and what types do use for division so
we're starting with unsigned car yes
please double our float do you want to
sum using double or float or divide
using double or float or both
well the summation is double is a bit
more expensive than summation in long
integers so maybe I want to do something
like this I summed up bytes in a long
integer because that's one cycle per
iteration and then when I do the
division I definitely don't want to do
the integral division because either I
get your average pics is like 8 right I
want the fractional number I want the
full information so I do the division in
double sole of a Sun we are encountering
this complicated world in which
integrals must be stunned another
integral type but different than the
original integral potentially and the
division should occur in a kind of some
fractional type right so this is the
right way to average integrals I don't
think you want to average intercourse
and truncate like you know like an idiot
in the last step you of course I'm going
to throw away all of this information I
don't care no you do want the
information otherwise use some by hand
right then we have things like custom
numerix big integer ok I thought this is
fancy you really bought it
big integer things like if infinite
precision reals and all that stuff and
worst of all there are sequences of
which I don't know the lengths in
advance they're singly linked lists as
filters on other sequences there file
streams etc anything that comes as a
stream does it don't know the length in
advance right however there are things
that you know the length in advance of
and for those
you don't want to do this extra work of
plus plus plus plus plus plus right you
don't add all these additions because
they take time so all of a sudden we're
looking at two classes of algorithms we
have summation of things that are
countable into that I know the size of
and I'm looking at summation of things
that I don't know the size of in advance
so I need to keep a track of it myself
so remember I mentioned in the very
beginning there's a style of form of
duplication that we trained ourselves to
ignore there is and this is it it's a
manifestation of it
right another thing is all real numerix
should use the wrong element type for
summon division every that's floating
point or whatever infinite Persinger
real you name it should use its own
element type for summation and division
all buildings signed the integrals
should carry their sum as longer you
long for efficiency as I said it would
be silly to sum all by Tina's bite but
division goes out goes as double and all
custom integrals should carry the sum as
their own type but if I to divide to
double this is contentious maybe it's
not the best decision but I couldn't
find a better one so with these two
slides this guy and the previous guy we
are having a specification that we need
to implement so we are looking at I
don't know let's let's say maybe 30
lines of specification right so you
should you know whenever the type is a
you know small integer put in a long
whenever it's a small integers on sign
Poona sign long divided by double if
it's custom whatever so we have a number
of decisions that inform our simple loop
here so let's proceed and implement that
specification and in the D language it
turns out it's it's simple to express
what we want to do so first of like
alias would be undefined this name to to
supplant this guy so we alias e to be
the element type of
the sequence if if it's an array of
doubles that would be double if it's
another vintages that will be int and so
on
so it would be my element type now I'm
gonna do something interesting I do a
query on the capability of type II
static if is typeof e of 0.0 what do you
think this guy does yes please thank you
exactly so this is a capability test I'm
trying to initialize an object of type
II with the constant 0.0 which is a
floating-point constant if that works
the result is going to have a valid type
ie II and the study give queries whether
that type exists whether the expression
is correct and compatible if is an int
in the D language you cannot initialize
an int from a floating point value you
cannot and it shouldn't it shouldn't be
in C even but that's side story right so
you can't stay floating point number and
cram it into an integer it doesn't fit
Sense and Sensibility
so therefore if is int and you're trying
to create an int from 0.0 it's just not
going to work so the static if is going
to return false which means here I have
all of my fractional types user-defined
built in double float 80-bit double
unlimited precision real point number
you name it if it can initiate if I can
initialize it from a floating point
number it's a floating point number okay
in that case I'm going to say that's
this my summation type is going to be
exactly the element and I'm calling
unqualified on it because I don't want
to be like immutable or cons
I just wanted to be mutable so I'm
unqualified the type I'm removing the
potential qualifies that to prevent me
from changing it and this is the
division type that is going to be the
exact same element otherwise so this is
all of my fractional numbers everything
that's real well the second capability
test are you an integral type so I'm
looking at by the way this Bank here
this the C++ translation would look like
that right that's not the love sign it's
just angle brackets I'm sorry to be
prosaic here so whenever it's like bang
in the D language it means it's like a
template instantiation right so if the
type is integral then we we do some more
digging because we want to choose signed
types versus unsigned types for the
summation and you test well is the the
smallest representable e is it less than
zero if it's less than zero that's a
number that can be both negative and
positive otherwise it's unsigned because
unsigned numbers don't have negative
can't represent negative numbers and
finally you know the default case I'm
going to go if this must be something
user-defined and I'm going to go with on
quali and double so this implementation
implements the specification that we
just thought about right what happens
here what happens there at this point I
have two types one is s and one is D s
is the summation type D is the division
type and what's left to do is to proceed
with the algorithm remember we had two
algorithms one was for things I know the
length of in advance
one was for things I have no idea about
the length in advance in a traditional
approach I would implement two the two
algorithms separately I would duplicate
the code
in here we're going to do something much
simpler and more compact which is innum
has length equals these type of items
dot length what is this
thank you so it queries whether this
expression has a type ie
it exists it's compatible it type checks
it it's correct
so it's essentially I'm asking do you
have a method called length and in the
CI in the D language the way it goes is
if you implement length you're required
to implement it to mean actually the
length of a sequence you could of course
you could be perverse and implement
length to not do that into the return a
string what the health right but that
would you know you can subvert any type
system and any introspection system yes
what if the container has a method
that's called length but is slow it
solvent that would be a program mistake
there'll be a mistake in the D language
there's a method called walk length
which is oven and best-effort so it
solve an oreo of anything if you can but
this is not best effort this is if you
implement it ever you must call it if
you implement it ever it must be all one
otherwise use walk length so length
means of one length and again I'm doing
a capability test well in him has length
equals is this guy so has length is sort
of a compile-time boolean value right it
means this guy is telling me during
compilation not at runtime not
dynamically it's telling me during
compilation what are the type I got
knows its length or not so at this point
I can say okay sure so if it has length
then I know the length so I'm
initializing and from items
length otherwise I'm going in Eliza's
with zero and not going to it
compute it and of course inside the loop
I have another study gift because I want
to increment it conditionally now the
nice thing is that I get to reuse a lot
of the you know a lot of the other
things in this function instead of
writing to artifacts that are completely
sort of separate independent mostly
duplicate the nice thing is that this
does scale I've looked at many code
bases in the D language starting from
the standard library and there's hedge
funds using the D language and there's a
networking companies using it and that's
such like that it's static if occurs
with the same frequency as if I carry
eight lines every eight lines you make a
design decision every eight lines you
fork you fork what you do you don't
forget runtime you fork in design space
so this is what I think is really
remarkable that that you get this
Fourier transform of the if statement
which is in time domain because if means
like I'm going to go through different
paths during runtime with static if and
going through different paths during
compilation I decide to do different
things to generate code different ways
so this is going to generate different
functions for different types and it's
going to generate the best function for
each type so you know there's there'll
be like there's a lot of aftermath here
like what do we do then T inputs we
return nan here you can handle it
outside some I don't see this as an
important problem
who knows about the kahan algorithm
thank you
okay the Bloomberg first folks right
you're not that Bloomberg okay for that
the folks would do real math okay so
these it turns out that if you sum any
doubles you're going to consider this
you have some very large numbers and you
have a lot of small numbers and if you
sum increasingly the small numbers you
some two very large numbers the large
number is going to kind of say oh this
is too small I'm not going to modify
myself so you're going to get even
though you have a very long tail of
small numbers those are not going to
count for the actual average and so you
get this propagating error problem
fortunately there are some very clever
algorithms which i recommend you google
for these are interesting exercises in
algorithm design you they cancel it they
canceled the the error progressively as
they some numbers and they're very
interesting and of course you want to do
that for floating-point numbers because
you get much better results at a small
cost inefficiency
so you know I have a few second-order
insights after we looked at this this
definition here so what's cool about OOP
he defined interfaces and classes and
the override methods to account for the
differences between interfaces and
classes who thinks woop is awesome one
yes yes one okay this is the right
audience you can go so you know OOP has
its limitations I mean many people
thought is going to be like amazing in
the 90s and early 2000s and then kind of
wait a second we can't do all these
things we want to do with OOP
right and then one yeah we have in C++
in the c-plus Emil year we have the
journey programming notion is like ah
let's define generic algorithms we
devise data requirements we specialize
across this thing a BTS and etc etc and
it looks like neither of these
fundamental approaches is doing the
right thing by our you know but I won't
want to do we want to implement code
without application that expresses what
we want to do it doesn't seem to cut
just right the proverbial pie and I
think what happens is in in OOP we have
type information wastage the typing
range is thrown away is like are just
renowned virtuals and you're good yeah
they're gonna be seven times of slow but
you're good who cares what seven times
between friends so you know you lose the
type information by inheritance and type
II erasure or you can overuse types by
doing a lot of type based meta
programming like in in several circles
you would do a lot of complicated type
base meta programming to do actually
pretty trivial things that are easy
should be easy should be simple should
be trivial and I think the key to the
kingdom here
is introspection you should be able to
look at the type while you compile your
code and make decisions depending on
what that type is knows what to do you
can consider a pipe at the the most
basic level as a as an advertisement for
what he can do
you know we're coding are like Java Java
JavaScript okay so anyway in these
languages it's quite common to open a
class you know look at a class and look
at its methods and treat them as
capabilities oh this guy knows how to do
bark and hardens or to eat not knows how
to do meow so therefore I can use these
methods in a specific manner so the type
is you know the methods of a type the
interface of a type is a is really an
advertisement for other type is able to
do and why not I ask why not open the
type during compilation ask the type
what he can do and generate code
depending on those this is what I think
is going to be big in the next decade in
programming introspection reflection and
static code generation and I noticed
that a lot of programmers consider code
size some sort of a measure of their
prowess as programmers especially like
when you you know when I began and we
were like to this day when I write first
1,000 lines of seeing it was awesome
it was a single function by the way it
does just mean like oh yeah I have a
main that's 1,000 lines worth and if you
feel it's like oh it means it's you know
I'm a good programmer I wrote a lot of
code it must be that I saw something
interesting and sadly this kind of
stayed with me for a while so I and I
think that impede
my development as a programmer because
actually the the amount of code ridden
is cost is not profit like a good
manager who asked you know what the
d-team plan that feature yes how many
lines did that cost you what was the
price of that feature yeah it cuz like
you know six thousand lines of code
maybe that's too much you we pay too
much for this let's scrap it loud and
pay extra to yeah pay extra to scrap
actually you know on on github they show
you the numbers of the lines you add and
the numbers the lines you do eat right
so you know I would pay people on the
the sum of the absolute of the tomb like
if you had some lines and delete some
lines I'm taking at the you know the
absolute value of the lines deleted and
I would add it to the lines here and
it's like actually actually not I would
put minus in front of the lines added
put minus so that I said put plus on the
lines deleted and pay people based on
that awesome concert where do we start
okay so like I like to count lines
because I want every line to count to be
meaningful so average can average
anything average of all the most average
function there is it has 26 lines of
code three lines are support imports and
naming thirteen lines are the design
specification which from the slides it
comes to about just as much time lines
our time domain sweat of the broad
that's my computation so ten lines is
the actual effort and most lines should
matter you know you should push
computation for they should make
progress in your computation you should
have every line in your code just push
the goddamn thing forward
sadly I'm seeing code at one time I was
like I'll look at the red black tree
implementation in C++ as long as I had a
simple thing do they store the boolean
to them massage it in a pointer to
restoring it separately the read-back
tree has some pointers has a
boolean some implementations take the
boolean and stick it in one the last the
least significant bit of a pointer you
know talking about for size right for
size purposes so how difficult it can be
you look at the red black tree
implementation in C++ you see whether
the boolean is massaged in there or not
I gave myself 15 minutes I could not do
it you don't you don't know where work
is being done crack open boost
crack up on GCC like you know the
standard library crack open anything
it's all good oh my goodness
they send you from one you don't know
where things are that we don't know
where work is being done I want work to
be visibly done in code not scaffolding
it's not like scaffolding that this one
line in 100 equals a plus one you got it
right I don't like that so it's
essential that we have all of this kind
of making decisions for design and are
making decisions about computation I'm
pushing the goddamn computation forward
they should go together in harmony
I mentioned this there's a bunch of use
of static if I think it's the the best
construct in the deprogram language and
it it changes the wasting quite quite
dramatically symmetry project as
symmetries is a hedge fund in London and
Weka is a networking company a network
storage company in Tel Aviv so I've kind
of was curious to look at their code and
they'd simply be using static if about
as frequently as if itself you can see a
page of D language code without a design
domain decision this should be the way
things should go in all programming
languages
what do you think should be filling the
dot-dot-dot in there most traders in the
stock market think in terms of profit
and loss Zen traders think in terms of
Bloomberg fees that's brutal
I didn't mean that so good trader will
think in terms of risk actually you know
their core risk manager so they all they
do is risk management so if something is
makes much much money less money it has
you know you gotta just say what's my
risk here what am i Reese how much am i
risking and how do I manage that risk so
this is the most important thing in in
trading in the stock market is figuring
out what your risk is what the exposure
is and going from there beginners tend
to think oh make you so much money I'm
losing so much money it's not about the
money it's about the risk and I would
contend that today most program things
in terms of things like data structures
and algorithms or interfaces and objects
or lists and functions pick your
language pick your favorites maybe even
over ownership if you're a Ross
programmer I think programmers should be
thinking in terms of introspection and
computation I look at types I figure out
what they can do and I push computation
forward using this information that I
gain don't forget a good language should
be in my opinion algorithmically
inclined keeping it real allows you to
do what you want to do and the code
reads like it does do what you want it
to do and your opinion may be different
and that's brilliant
thank you very much
[Applause]